So today we're going to talk about the
warning signs that can help you detect
if there's parasites in your body
but I have some news to break with you
regardless of what you're doing
health-wise chances are you have
parasites in your body right now they're
just not creating any problems now what
is a parasite a parasite could be either
a virus a worm a bacteria or a fungus
that has a very different relationship
with your body it's not a friendly
bacteria or a friendly microbe basically
leeches things from you creates problems
for you but in return it's there's no
benefits at all so that relationship is
more pathogenic now of course there's
even people that are parasitic they
leech off other people they don't
exchange back with people they just keep
taking and taking and taking and you
probably know some people like that but
as far as microbes go as long as you
have a relationship where there's
exchange then there's no problem but
these parasites are literally robbing
your nutrients okay and so let's go
through some of the symptoms that you're
going going to experience the first big
symptom has to do with your digestion
and all of these digestive reactions
from parasites are mainly due to your
own immune system trying to kill off
these unfriendly microbes okay and so
you're going to have usually diarrhea
like what would be positive about
diarrhea well it's a way of fleshing out
parasites so diarrhea is one of the most
common symptoms or signs that you have
parasites especially if it's kind of
right after maybe a long trip going out
of the country and you accidentally
drank the water from some place where
you don't have the immunity like other
people do other symptoms related to
immunity is nausea okay you feel
nauseous
that symptom is related again to your
immune system reaction to killing off
the parasite you can also have a lot of
bloating you can have a lot of gas you
can even have constipation now the next
symptom that you may experience from
having parasites how has to do with
fatigue mainly from the parasites
robbing your nutrients they're
competitive they're going to eat up all
the nutrients in your small intestine
and leave you deficient so you're going
to feel tired you're going to feel
lethargic you're going to feel wore out
you're just not going to have the energy
that you need not to mention the fatigue
coming from the immune system working
really hard to kill off the parasite and
it could be like high levels of
histamines too histamines are kind of
fatigue poisons that occur in immune
reactions now another common symptom
with parasites is itchiness in your
private parts now you can also have
itchiness
throughout your whole body but that
would be a common symptom of parasites
another common symptom would be mood
changes right it's going to affect your
mood you might feel irritable you may
have blood sugar problems simply because
what these microbes are doing to your
Chemistry you will probably have skin
changes eventually especially if you
have a worm infection like if it's
ringworm or roundworm you may have some
skin problems you might have redness or
some type of rash if you had a tick bite
as in Lyme disease many times you may
also have craving for milk sugar okay as
an ice cream or sweets the worst thing
you could do if you have a parasite
infection or even a Candida infection is
to continue to consume milk sugar or any
sweets at all now with some people
depending on how long you've had this
parasite infection you may find that
your appetite either goes up or goes
down depending on the stay of this
infection
you can completely lose your appetite or
probably in the beginning of this
infection you'll have more of an
appetite because you're not able to
benefit from the nutrients in the food
that you're eating because they're
robbing it but the other thing too with
infections in general is that one
defense mechanism that your body has
against infections is losing your
appetite and going on a fast which
indirectly strengthens your immune
system to fight this thing off better
like a lot of animals for example when
they get infections they lose their
appetite as well so this idea of eating
more to nourish your body isn't always
the best thing when it comes down to
your immune system now you may also have
brain fog as a common symptom from
parasites from both the immune reaction
as well as some of the byproducts or the
toxins that some of these parasites are
giving off as your immune system is
killing them and you may also experience
allergies
excessive sneezing
from having a parasite infection you
always want to find out when did these
symptoms start and what happened just
before the symptom in practice I had a
fairly large number of nurses that would
come in and many times I've noticed that
nurses tended to have more parasites one
common cause of getting an infection is
being in a hospital
which apparently is the worst place to
go if you're trying to avoid infections
because you have all the sick people
there right and you have this
concentrated group of sick people
with all these pathogens floating around
parasites are very very common about
three billion people a year in the world
get parasitic infections I think over
200 000 people die from parasites this
is why it's so important to understand
that your immune system is your best
weapon you need your immune system to
keep these parasites and pathogens in
check that's what it's there for and one
of the primary modes that these
pathogens have against you is
suppressing your immune system to block
nutrients like zinc vitamin D and other
nutrients so they can have the unfair
Advantage but you really need to put
attention on the immune system so if you
don't have this in consideration you can
be susceptible to
I don't know accidentally destroying
your immune system as you're trying to
destroy the pathogen or the disease so
really put attention on the importance
of your immune system in any treatment
that you get because as soon as you
suppress your immune system
you're more susceptible to more
infections more problems and this
definitely relates to your microbiome in
your gut the microbiome in your gut is
probably responsible for at least 75 to
up to 80 percent of your immune system
so above everything try like hectic to
keep those microbes alive and keep them
very happy and friendly and make sure
that relationship doesn't change to
being unfriendly because the environment
is so stressed out I mean there are like
over 300 000 different types of
parasites so they're all around us we
can't avoid them and we can't live in a
sterile environment so the greatest
weapon is just to take care of our
immune system so what is the best
antidotes to parasites okay well it
would be those natural antidotes that
have very powerful anti-parasitic
effects
um yet have the least side effects okay
so I'm gonna go through them right now
and there's four of them and there's a
lot of other things as well but these
are plant-based
see plants are also susceptible to
parasite infections and they've been for
eons uh developing certain strategies
and certain chemicals that kill off
parasites and we can piggyback on those
plants consume them
for that benefit for our own parasites
and so the number one antidote to
parasite says garlic so you want to eat
plenty of garlic number two wormwood
extract okay wormwood extract a very
potent anti-parasitic and it's a good
dewormer as well and the next one is
clove okay there are certain
phytonutrients in Clove that have potent
anti-parasitic effects then you get the
famous black walnut Hall extract it's
extracts from those outer covering of
the black walnut okay which is very very
uh pungent and very very potent against
parasites you don't see a lot of
parasites around the halls even for
animals for example the cattle that I'm
raising you can use apple cider vinegar
as a dewormer instead of a drug that's a
dewormer so why is that important
because anything that gives you more
acid in your stomach can help kill off
parasites probably one of the reasons
why people get parasites in the first
place is the pH of your stomach is not
acid enough to kill off the parasites
that are in your Foods so that stomach
acid is another really important barrier
to keep the microbes from surviving now
since we're on the topic of parasites
and digestive problems and especially
this one called diarrhea there's some
slightly different remedies involved
with diarrhea to stop the diarrhea that
I think would be very important for you
to learn about and I put that video up
right here check it out